[Music]
racism oopsie
accidental racism how could that
possibly happen this is just a
ridiculous uh branding you're either
racist or you're not there's no
in-between there is never any excuses
ever now let's see what these pathetic
posts on reddit have to say about
themselves I am estimating and
disgusting right freaking now it's a
small Museum but it really captures the
Australian spirit immigration museum
this is accidentally a better piece of
art than anything back ch-check oh
that's great it happens to the best of
us what can I say what else do we got a
very interesting adjective for
describing the color of a car okay we
have tango orange we had granite brain
fire brick red silky silver it's
superior white interesting very
interesting adjectives indeed it's just
interesting that those two words would
be used together Jesus Christ what kind
of car is this I am buying act and I'm
just kidding I'm kidding
excuse me I would like this superior
white police can you imagine anyone
buying this like actual races being like
yeah I Drive a super just to be clear I
do not support these racism claims video
memes okay so I'm pretty much legally
covered from any media as well that's a
disclaimer by the way just so we're
clear I didn't make these memes and I do
not endorse their messages I will have
or laugh at them these plates are color
coded it's accurate because the white
man is happy okay maybe that wasn't an
unnecessary comment but it what's funny
okay let's move on Jesus Christ is it
hot in here is it to adjust my racism
baby cut an organic baby carrier
I have no comment whatsoever except that
it's racist just to be clear guys side
told me to review this subreddit and
he's the biggest races I know all right
so I'm pretty covered by this looking to
purchase a kitten under $10 must be in
mint condition I have a black baby
looking for a kitten but thanks know it
is a kitten still don't want it but
thanks it must be in mint condition what
the hell does that mean the German
raised the fast in the fear god this is
a bad idea isn't it
I didn't think it would be like this
okay I don't know what I was expecting I
don't know what it was gonna happen but
here we are nonetheless and I'm
definitely committing I'm not picking
anything else to do today okay yeah I
should be more responsible and pick
another sub ready
I'm Way too deep in at this point okay
I'm basically reviewing this so you
don't have to so other people won't go
to this foul disgusting sub ready if
humans are 65% water Africans are just
thirty type percent human smash
immigrants welcome racism smash total
immigrants and welcome racism awareness
smash racism immigrants
well I'm just confused which one is it
I'm at a grocery store and a guy looks
at me then turns to his wife and says oh
yo we need naan bread I'm who accepted
okay that's kind of funny come on he was
he was just meaning it as well stirring
a square mug creates an interesting
shape of [ __ ] and I'm clicking away
alright The Amazing Race black family
yes is that their actual name like black
I'm so confused
celebrating single haha
ah yes it raises to laugh at them I
can't tell what are the lines go at this
I'm not mound making it
kanya says slavery was a choice gets
owned at the end of the video gets owned
he gets owned Konya gets owned Konya
gets owned oh no oh no no no a DD ADHD
sign up for concentration camp now hey
so that's what it's for
don't do this to my bull frankly frankly
hey I mean at least it'll have more food
on his side so the only white mouse a
razor makes supremacy just check in I'm
just checking I'm gonna say it the
n-word Oh cuz Brown flips is n-word this
is probably the greatest discovery the
internet has ever made
it's the ultimate Nemer you ever see
brown it's basically the new 420 or 69
just that hit an epic reference that
people just can't stop laughing at did
you know that Brown says in word if you
flip it incredible my life has been
brought new meaning I like what in the
world what color crazy old okay I guess
that's the color how is that
unintentional Adobe display old blacks
accurately or display old blacks as rich
black Jesus Christ how does this keep
happening I guess I shouldn't be asking
that question would you believe me if I
told you that this was the same plaza as
the anne frank exhibit jus talks moving
on everybody
sorry I read it and then I don't mind
spiders cockroaches it's Tomas - I just
love how they capitalized that is wrong
it was goddamn mosques oh great this is
Swedish so that makes it even funnier
Leah coming on 12 99 99 99 well I mean
it's simple supply and demand really
don't mess up your n words don't worry I
never do nucleus neutron nucleon nuclide
it's easy as ABCD popular rob the Jew
okay are we uploading this am I actually
black child playpen 69 that's a great
price that's it number Mexican Chinese
crackers and who said what racism
against white people isn't real sake in
my freaking head right now I don't like
this song I don't like okay moving on
mmm how did they not see this Microsoft
Office 2013 the basic essentials
Microsoft Office introductory Microsoft
Office interests
it's so obvious I feel like it's
intentional racism somebody just snuck
it in there can I get the white month
six different colors give me the white
bracelet please I stand for power
I don't by the way just for the record
okay stop pretending your racism is
patriotism racism I want that shirt
where can i buy that shirt that's a
great message that I stand for dub
nourishing lotion from normal to dark
skin normal skin everybody welcome to
the normal club proud to be part of it
bottom item of World of Warcraft today
sandals of the blackest Jesus Christ the
placement of YouTube's play but yeah
man that looks strangely a lot like
jacksepticeye there's an Indian version
of Jackson decay god damn hey can you
just can you just move a little bit to
the left please
but why I would have stand next to the
truck just but why tell me what it says
[Music]
hey good choice of silhouette as well
Jesus Christ oh my god stop playable
swarm playable swarm Chinese Oh lame Oh
God Black Panther the only movie in all
of Walmart with an anti-theft device wow
great Walmart The Oprah Winfrey Show an
ape has conversation with Jesus Christ
Lego Marvel superheroes minifigure
Spider Man with white power blast god
[ __ ] damn it stop saudi skills saudis
god damn it stop time for a bath clean
baby stop
did someone blink stop really target
stop please
ahh god damn it it's everywhere it's
everywhere god damn it please that's ok
we had a good time here today don't tell
anyone you saw this video don't tell
anyone
no-one if no one tells anyone the video
will be fine it will be fine I trust me
it's gonna be fine it's gonna be great
it's gonna be ok it'll be fine and we
pine now for real obviously it says
jokes and I think what's funny about it
it's it's not even jokes I mean you can
stop making these kind of jokes you can
forbid the humor and say that it's not
ok but obviously at the end of the day
unintentional racism will always always
exist because people are always stupid
just like real racism will always exist
because people are stupid
unfortunately hope that message comes
across clear that I am 100% races exist
not not sorry I thought it would be
funny
joke but then I realized people will
just take it out of context so I'm just
gonna go ahead and say I am 100% goodbye
everybody
smash like on this video if you enjoyed
it check out merch check out tuber
simulator guys the game is still very
epic and as always
brofist yeah there we go I have a pimple
right here and it's been the whole video
hope you enjoyed that